[Music]
President Trump said it was honored to
meet me it's not a normal human being
it's the dictator he wanted my head cut
off and was willing to pay a hundred
thousand there's a wholeness thing in me
and no matter how big the band was I
wasn't able to figure that out
so I dealt with the through heroin
addiction fail to reach an agreement
summit it was hoped the talks in Vietnam
would lead to the rover states
demonization and a hastily arranged
press conference President Trump blamed
the breakdown on North Korea's
insistence that all sanctions be lifted
without the country committing to
eliminate its nuclear arsenal do we
spend pretty much all day with kim
jeong-hoon
he's quite a guy and quite a character
[Music]
from Kim's summit but then the news of
no deal came further splitting opinion
on this already divided Peninsula I
hoped the relationship could be better
than now I am very sad of that because
the negotiation is not very good I agree
with the trauma case because of the
nuclear bomb every of the country are
really scared about the North Korea and
also weary South Korea but we really
still afraid about the North Korea stuff
so I really agree that was what Trump
did this is now a critical time in the
Korean Peninsula peace process the US
has pledged to keep on talking
but a failure to get sanctions lifted
could mean Kim jong-un's no longer
listening what I was really worrying
that president Trump will keep he
weighed too much on this summit on
behalf of North can reason for example
like we talked about in your chlorides
days and in the past but right now it's
like they're talking about only freezing
their nuclear capabilities so I was so
worried about that we are in exchange of
freezing team freezing the nuclear you
know capabilities and the release the
sanctions that was I was really worrying
but I was so happy this morning seeing
news that President Trump didn't sign
any contract and he left the room so I
think he did one of the best things in
during his prison presidency period with
this from last year or dictator he
appeared on a news media very suddenly
and then now from the Singapore Hanoi
summit we the world saw Kim jong-un and
then from the Singapore summit people
kind of forgot about about what he'd
done to his own people in North Korea he
is murdered he killed so many innocent
American people in a prison camp and the
in public execution which is happening
even today at this moment and we know
that how he killed his own uncle and his
half-brother in exile the assassination
but like we forgot about and then he
just put like a piece mask on his face
like as he he wanted to bring the peace
to the world
and then many people are saying even in
America in South Korea oh he's a nice
guy or like he looked smart he became
kind of celebrity right now so this
really makes me annoying a specific
president Trump said it was honored to
meet in wind passes observed to me it's
not a normal human being
it's the dictator
leaders around the world of this week
called for restraint from Pakistan and
India following an escalation of
tensions in Kashmir the conflict in the
disputed region intensified after
Pakistan said it had shot down two
Indian warplanes and captured a pilot it
follows a suicide bombing in Indian
controlled Srinagar and a retaliatory
attack on what was believed to be
militants in the town of Bala cot in
Pakistan both countries have carried out
airstrikes against each other the first
time in history that two nuclear-armed
powers have done so I spoke to
Pakistan's High Commissioner to the UK
Mohammad nafeez Zakaria we have not only
offered this thing to India but we have
also reached out to the UN we have
reached out to the countries friendly
countries like UK to play their role in
de-escalating the situation over there
because we want peace we want peace in
the region so that people of the region
could benefit from the economic
potential of that region that region
possesses okay it's an intractable
problem a very difficult problem Kashmir
you mentioned Britain there what would
you want Britain or the Foreign
Secretary Jeremy Hunt to do about
Kashmir this is an internationally
recognized issue on the agenda of UN
Security Council we would like the UN
Security Council resolutions on Kashmir
to be implemented and and the issue
should be resolved in accordance with
the UN Security Council resolutions and
we see the role of United Kingdom being
a permanent member of the UN Security
Council and also having historical
linkages with both the countries as well
as their linkages are there their
relevance to the dispute of Kashmir one
concern I think the world has is that
Imran Khan himself was saying earlier
that if this escalates there's no way
that he can control it that the
politicians can't control it is the
truth here that the it is the military
the army that that controls things in
Pakistan I think we have heard of a
Democrat
transition successfully and I believe
that all these statements are coming
from the political leadership and I
think whatever they are saying is just
very much in front of you we they are
saying that this India must be counseled
to refrain from escalating tension
because we know the perils one of the
world's most infamous criminals El Chapo
is facing the prospect of dying in an
American prison after being convicted
and jailed for life for trafficking
offenses earlier this month but bringing
drokken Guzman to justice was not easy
the American authorities spent over
three decades trying to catch the former
drug cartel leader he had put two bounty
on my head in 2007 and from that point
on it was extremely personal for me and
I made sure that the agents and
policemen that we worked with kept him
as a high priority for all these years I
gather he was wanting your head on a
plate basically yeah I had arrived in El
Paso which was directly across the river
from Juarez he was embroiled in a battle
with two other cartels there and I gave
an interview to a newspaper where I said
look I was sent down here to dismantle
his organization and to eventually hook
him up and bring him to justice and he
certainly didn't like what I said and
then shortly after that some of our
Mexican friends notified us that they
had come across information where he
wanted my head cut off and was willing
to pay a hundred thousand right wasn't a
lot right no I mean did that did that
that presumably deterred you did it or
did it so you know maybe even more keen
to get him know that really lit the fire
in me and and and literally hundreds of
heroic DEA agents that I worked with so
it was really it was our calling from
that point forward and we knew it was
going to be a tough tough job because of
the situation in Mexico but we never
really gave up and I sure like where he
said
right now right and now he's escaped
once before and I think you're about to
retire when he escaped and you went
after him again and now he is
incarcerated I mean do you fear he might
escape this time as well no that's the
furthest thing from my mind the prison
that he's most likely going to is the
most high security prison in the u.s.
system and not only has no one escaped
there hasn't even been an attempt so I
think he's going to be in his little 3
by 5 cell for the rest of his life and
that suits me just fine during the 1991
Gulf War
Chris Ryan formed part of the eight-man
team chosen for the famous drama though
to zero issues he would be the only one
to escape from Iraq after three of his
colleagues were killed and for capture
he went on to write about his
experiences this book the one that got
away
an analyst turned his hand to children's
literature to try to champion literacy
and disadvantaged areas we caught up
with him about 15 years ago I would be
doing an adult event and a lot of
fathers would bring their young sons in
and these children would ask why don't
you do a story for us because father
won't let me read you no adult your
adult novel for obvious reasons and this
is the third series I've done now it
wasn't until I got into schools that
actually it hit me the problem we have
with young teenage boys between the ages
of 13 and 16 who actually have
difficulty reading and in some cases
they've never read a book before and I
feel quite strongly about this now you
know a young child at 16 leaving school
his chances of getting a decent job
minimal course other wanted join gangs
so the thing is you and the toughest
gang well yes the right gang no the big
difference being when when I joined the
army I ended up not in an organization
that educated you trained you and then
you know sent you all over the world and
it was a very disciplined gang certainly
within the SAS the ethos there is
failure is not an option and they expect
you to become become top of the class
you know whether it's mentally or
physically you have to really work
and I'm trying to pass this on to young
boys it's very difficult for them at the
moment because they're hit with you know
a lot of TV a lot of computer games and
everything is fed to them and to try and
encourage a young boy to open up a book
and get hooked on it and not just one of
my rooks any type of book I'll always
say to a child who has difficulty
reading what is your favorite subject
pick a book that basically goes through
that subject and you will be hooked on
this so what is it about your book that
you think you're hoping will will suck
them in and will will give them that bug
for reading well basically I go back to
when I was that age and I think what
would I like to read what would excite
me obviously I use my experiences of
being in the SAS water dung and in
trying channel channel that in you know
into the individual leading or becoming
a team member and succeeding it whatever
they do amongst you may well have
noticed that I'm no longer the studio
and there's a very good reason for that
our next two guests from the Harlan a
little bit might be a little bit of
physical effort lovely to see both of
you you're gonna try and take us through
a little bit of a skill routine I think
if you're trying and help me out because
of course you're coming here to the UK I
want to with the Globetrotters in April
April tell us what people can expect
from the Harlem Globetrotters there
can't be many people who don't know of
the team and its headstream it's been
going since the 1920s yes you can expect
a lot of a lot of entertainment a lot of
best good basketball a lot of tricks a
lot of high-flying dunks just over our
good time so someone's gonna show me how
to do something here at least have a go
help me out here just like didn't bring
a neck here otherwise have been stuffing
[Music]
[Music]
thank you very much
so tell us just a little bit about the
history of the Globetrotters where did
it come from and watch the practice
these days we started in 1926 and
Chicago Illinois and the first game was
January 7 1927 and iPhone is a superstar
years I've seen a profile on finals like
men on women easy mortgage hands and
they're all over the Pioneers over so
we're just trying to keep on the legacy
that most people think that because we
have the name Harlem yeah attached to
our name is because we're from Harlem
but we're not is because back then all
of the African American yeah I need to
okay anything
[Music]
now the infamous rock stars of the 80s
who garnered as much attention for their
bad behavior at their music and now a
new biopic is set to tell their barely
believable tune the dirt follows the
trials and tribulations of the iconic
American rock groups Motley Fool from
their information for the height of
their success
[Music]
the fans that die for some anarchy
so let's give it to
[Applause]
we lived it we live to actually regret a
lot of it and we've learned from it and
what who we are in 2019 is not who we
were at the time of the film was made
but we feel that with honest filmmaking
you have to leave it all in you know it
doesn't matter if it's about prohibition
or the colonial period burning which is
you can't leave stuff out and it was
important for us to show because you
show a band that came out of an era that
was very vanilla in Los Angeles there
was a new wave punk was a very powerful
about you guys there was a there was
nothing Bell about it well but that's
that's one of the great things that
Motley's allowed us to do as producers
the sixties the Beatles glamorized acid
so did the Jefferson Airplane in
haight-ashbury and in the sixties and
seventies Keith Richards was a heroin
addict and these were kids who saw their
heroes glamorize drugs to be honest
about that and show in the movie that
nothing good happens from that and D
glamorize it I think takes courage and
motley allowed us to do that as
producers you had big challenges with
heroin didn't you yeah it was really
hard for me well my mom well my dad
first left when I was three my mom is
six I was raised by my grandparents we
traveled a lot so there was always sort
of something missing
as far as having a family and when I
started putting bands together in the
late 70s I started feeling a connection
to something more than just the music it
was this bond and Motley Crue really was
my first family and did you know I died
we never were able to resolve our
differences and that's something that's
you know I have to live with so there
was there was a hole missing and mean
and no matter how big the band was I
wasn't able to figure that out I was too
young I didn't have the experience life
experience
and so I dealt with it through heroin
addiction and then when I got clean and
sober and went through therapy and Rehab
and you know wanted to be a better man
and I'm now today I'm father of four I
have a young daughter on the way Mary
yeah I'm very very excited about that
did you get to a stage with the with the
band where you saw these guys are just
crazy I can't have anything more to do
with him multiple times that said Nicky
is a great partner and has always been
able to lead this band and whenever I
told him I wanted to quit he said you
can't and I value the partnership that
much what impression do you want people
to come away with that you can learn
from your lessons and that you can
survive and it's a family movie not us
and it's a family movie it's a movie
about a family dysfunctional at times at
the at the top of our game at times
selling out stadiums and other times
falling apart
[Music]
very joyous occasion people glad I won
all over the world especially the
People's Republic of Brooklyn New York
so I'm happy I'm here celebrating Roger
and Brian are so excited that the movie
has been received the way it has as am i
and to celebrate the film tonight was
such an honor I did have a little cameo
in the movie yes I was the trucker
tempting Freddy at the rest stop so so
in the film and on stage with Queen to
this day I like to think to myself for
Freddy that perhaps I'm repping the
queer spirit you didn't win this evening
we were rooting for you but then I won I
won please believe me I'm still winning
Olivia did speech was classic Olivia
Goldman it's hilarious make your lover
even more on this experience together
yeah yeah and I went with on the Iron
Lady two have known each other some
years I was thrilled that she won I
think she's I think she's probably still
crying just to stop Alfonso I mean no I
mean seeing him up there it's my heart
with joy yeah what is he like as a box
what is he like as a director oh my god
he's he's amazing what he did it was
just a blessing for actors he really
like made it everything easy he gave us
all the tools so we could go into a
deeper real-life experience
I think it's been phenomenal and it was
very exciting to have 10 nominations
America is always a little bit
unpredictable because they tend to sort
of look after their own perhaps I should
say just like maybe at the BAFTAs we
expect to be looked after there and I
think we did incredibly well and the
right person was I was just there to
enjoy the night but it was so good to
see that the guys win and there's a lot
of hard work that's obviously gone into
it and to see them receive that kind of
recognition is really wonderful come on
I think you're doing yourself a
disservice you've stepped in at the last
minute and you you know you've been an
integral part of saving this film some
people say well that's but they they're
free to say that I'm not going to argue
with them I I did I was asked on the
Thursday and I started on the Monday so
it was quite a quick turnaround and I
and I shot about a month of the film and
there was a there for the Edit so yes
but I mean it's it's I mean of course it
would be nice to me to acknowledge that
and people do acknowledge it but really
it's about what Ramy achieved tonight
and what what that ensemble cast
achieved tonight really when I did the
Oscars back in 2015 and I got nominated
I was honestly terrified so every year I
watch the awards understanding it really
is one of the scariest stages in the
world
what do you think about Lady gaga Oh
amazing phenomenal huge fan well there's
a beautiful performance everyone wasn't
incredible
Olivia's speech was the highlight of my
whole night I mean was the best speech
of the night it's the realest most
authentic thing I've heard I mean she's
an angel is amazing